octobre est un roman de zoé wikong c'est
une auteure sud africaine qui est assez
peu traduite en france elle a le mérite
d'avoir une très belle écriture elle est
reconnue par ses pairs et notamment par
toni morrison tendance à encenser tous
ses romans
là on suit l'histoire de mercia qui est
une prof de littérature en écosse avait
une cinquantaine d'années elle vient
d'être quittée par son son compagnon
avec qui elle est restée des années sans
vraiment de raison et c'est l'occasion
pour elle de revenir un peu sur son
passé sur ses origines lé sud africaine
elle est partie d'afrique du sud depuis
très longtemps on est en octobre en
écosse elle déteste l'automne en écosse
elle préfère l'automne en afrique du sud
elle aimerait bien y retourner et elle
reçoit juste à ce moment là la lettre de
son frère qu'il appelle à l'aide
elle le rejoint donc en afrique du sud
et là elle va se retrouver confronté à
tous sont passés à ses racines elle va
redécouvrir ce pays qu'elle a connues
mais plutôt à l'époque de l'apartheid et
elle va elle va prendre en charge ce
frère qui est alcoolique qui a tendance
à être assez violent avec sa femme et
qui en fait ne s'est pas remis de la
relation avec leur père qui était
quelqu'un d'un peu particulier et elle
va surtout endosser un rôle de tante
donc avec son petit neveu qu'elle n'a
jamais connue et ça va être l'occasion
pour elle de transmettre plein de choses
et notamment son amour pour ce pays
qu'elle a dû quitter un peu de force
mais qu'elle regrettait qu'elle a
vraiment envie de redécouvrir
donc je vais vous présenter six jours
donc ce sont les six jours qui se sont
déroulés juste après l'acquittement des
quatre policiers qui ont passé à tabac
rodney king dans les années 90 à los
angeles
donc pendant ces six jours dix sept
personnes sont en prise avec cette
guérilla urbaine donc on va suivre in
situ tous les ressentis et toute la vie
à travers la vision d'un pompier d'une
infirmière d'un gang de d'un groupe
d'autodéfense de la communauté coréenne
tout ce qui s'est passé durant ces six
jours donc il ya une toute une
chronologie durant le livre dont il ya
six chapitres et ce sont ces six fameuse
jours juste après l'acquittement des des
policiers le livre va démêler tous les
liens qui unissent et 17 personnes qui
se connaissent ou pas durant les six
jours donc qui ont suivi l'acquittement
donc on va suivre ses personnages tout à
travers de leur vie et on va les
rencontrer les uns après les autres et
pour comprendre un peu et démêler le fil
de ce récit c'est un récit très fort
très imprégné par la culture américaine
et par la culture des ghettos que ariane
gatiss décline tout au long de son
ouvrage
pour ce premier roman traduit en
français dorian gatiss donc on voit
qu'il ya un gros travail de
documentation qui a été fait en amont
pour à écrire qui s'est vraiment infuser
de toutes les recommandations des
différents soit des pompiers parce que
les pompiers finalement sont très peu
très peu été interrogé sur sur ces
émeutes là et il a aussi eu un gros
travail avec les gangs
si je devais résumer ce livre on pourra
dire que c'est un mix entre championnes
de d'altman avec un petit bout de
colosses de dennis hopper est sous une
bo de
de ben harper le tome 1 de lazarus
intitulé pour la famille de roeck à
l'arc et arcas est le premier tome d'une
série de comics qui ont connu un grand
succès aux états unis
on est dans un futur proche la planète a
connu une immense crise économique et
sociale
les frontières ne sont plus politiques
ou géographiques mais elles sont créées
en fonction de la richesse de certaines
familles il ya un système féodal qui a
été instaurée donc il y à la famille qui
évidemment au dessus de tout le monde
puis les serres et enfin ceux qu'on
qualifie de déchets donc c'est ce qu'ils
ne servent absolument pas aux familles
est une population qui ne fait que leur
coûter et qu'il faut nourrir
malgré eux dans ce système de famille
chaque famille à ce qu'on appelle un
lazare le lazare est une est un humain
qui a été créée exprès pour le combat
donc on va suivre dans la série lazarus
le lazare de la famille carlyle qui est
une des familles les plus puissantes de
la planète et cela hasard c'est une
jeune femme qui s'appelle eve qui est
persuadé d'être la fille de chair et de
sang de son père et de sa mère et qui a
été créé génétiquement et qui est là
pour défendre les intérêts de sa famille
donc c'est assez violent mais c'est
c'est un scénario assez classique
finalement un système féodal une guerre
fratricide une créature qui se posent
des questions sur ses sentiments ça la
raison qu'elle a d'être sur terre et
c'est une bonne série
le deuxième tome est déjà sorti les
aussi bien dans chaque tome on nous tend
un peu des pistes à découvrir et puis on
n'a pas forcément la résolution
immédiate mais on espère que dans le
troisième tome ce sera le cas et ainsi
de suite
qui vivra kimura c'est la question
centrale de cet ouvrage de savoir qui
arrivera survivre dans des moments soit
de pandémie de guerre de famine et la
question donc de qui sera écarté dans un
groupe où normalement tout le monde doit
survivre enfin la question centrale donc
et philosophique c'est finalement qui
écarté et qui conservait alors il est
aussi question d'éthique morale et
d'éthique médicale dans ce livre
concernant par exemple les greffons a
qui ont des dix finalement certains y
font sur des cadavres
aussi concernant tous les vaccins à qui
on dédie les vaccins alors se pose la
réflexion de la question économique ou
de la question humanitaire dont toute la
réflexion du livre va se porter sur
comment réagir vis-à-vis de ces crises
et quelles décisions doit-on prendre
vis-à-vis de tout ça ce que moi j'ai
trouvé très troublant et finalement très
intéressant et très profond dans ce
livre c'est que l'auteur met en
perspective des événements historiques
comme la shoah comme la guerre comme la
famine
en afrique est elle-même en perspective
vis-à-vis de fiction contemporaine
donc elle met par exemple spider man qui
a le choix entre sauver une vingtaine de
gamins qui sont bloqués dans un
téléphérique ou sauver mary jane
voilà donc cette façon de convaincre non
que ce soit les romans jeunesse où
toutes les fictions contemporaines
d'avoir fait ce choix de sélection entre
qui doit rester et qui doit doit mourir
l'auteur s'articule tout autour d'eux
donc de nos fictions qui sont là de tous
les jours que l'on peut voir soit dans
nos romans soit dans le film et c'est
question l'art est aussi central sur ces
fictions tout au long du livre l'auteur
nous montre le lien qui peuvent donc
exister entre les fictions
contemporaines et tous les événements
tragiques qui ont pu avoir lieu durant
toute l'histoire et que finalement ce
n'est pas forcément le tragique qui
prend le dessus et on peut avoir une
vraie réflexion concernant ces décisions